je ne sais pas si on enchaîne oui on
enchaîne alors alors
enchaînons alors une autre chanson que
j'aime autant que
l'autre une chanson qui s qui est
vachement bien et alors justement c'est
son anniversaire aujourd'hui cette
chanson elle a 25 ans aujourd'hui
Thierry ardissant on parlait tout à
l'heure et elle s'appelle love me do
donc je
elle est drô elle est quand même
drôlement
bien et alors cette chanson j'ai chanté
plein de chansons quand j'étais au lycée
des chansons des Beatles celle-là je
l'avais jamais chanté et puis avec
Jackie tout à l'heure on a répété 2
secondes et on va voir ce que ça donne
voyons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors love love me do you know I love
you I always be true so
please love me
do love me
do love love me do you know I love you
I'll always be TR so please
love me
do love me
do someone to love
somebody
you to
love some like
you love love me to you know I love you
I'll always be
[Musique]
ref encore
coup always be so
please love me
to love me
do yeah love me
do love
[Musique]
me